[Music]
that was like I think that was our first
or second way it was probably in reality
maybe our third official hug what are
you looking for
oh my notes okay all right listen here
no no this is my good side in terms of
that we're all set now remember I just
you know people don't know our
friendships that's right it was
important to kind of cover used to have
a podcast you I still have I still do it
thanks for listening I should though it
seems like it's doing good stuff for you
on the podcast our friendship was kind
of made public I call you my best worst
friend right or my worst best friend and
you say stuff to me that like you know
you said I had Twitter followers more
than you and then you asked me why but
quickly supplied your own hypothesis
which was that you think it's all guys
that just want to have sex with me now
well that's flattering / really deeply
insulting I still thought it would be
interesting to check in on where you're
at with your Twitter followers
okay I'm currently at 238 38,000 feet is
that do you know I don't know 106 okay
you're getting up there but if we were
going with my hypothesis that means I
feel like there are a lot of Internet
people that probably do want to get get
get with the Peretti well you sleep with
a lot of your followers is that talking
out of school that's not true how many
of you have slept with feet oh that's
cool that's not true that's not true
would you sleep with a fan whoo I was
going in a different direction
Oh would you sleep with me wait what
circumstance would it be that I would
sleep with you post-apocalyptic but at
that point why not just like jump off
the side of a mountain do you know what
I mean I need you in my life we I have a
lot of positivity around me yeah and I
need to plug in well I need to like
you're already getting such a good head
start on negativity just walk around in
those pants
[Music]